quantum physics is spooky
the theory implies that tiny particles
like electrons or photons can be in
different states at the same time and
can influence each other even over large
distances scientists like Einstein
didn't believe that was possible but now
a fiendishly clever experiment has
finally proven that even particles
physically separated from each other can
influence each other instantaneously the
experiment is called a Bell test and
usually involves two particles each
particle can be in one of two states
here represented by red and green but in
the Bell test the two particles are
entangled which means that when one
particle is green the other has to be
red and vice-versa now quantum physics
says that both particles actually exist
in both states at the same time that is
until you measure them and if they're
entangled when you measure one of them
the other will also instantly resolve
into the other state it's as if the
distant particles are somehow
influencing each other faster than the
speed of light sounds impossible
Einstein certainly thought so scientists
have been trying different versions of
the Bell test for decades and it seems
like quantum theory is right but there
are two problems you can do the Bell
test with photons but it's hard to
detect them all so we don't know what
information we might be missing
electrons are easier to detect but the
problem here is getting them far enough
apart while keeping them entangled if
they're too close together the measured
electron could be communicating with its
partner without breaking the speed of
light so we can't be sure that they're
influencing each other instantly
these two loopholes in the bail test
meant that Einstein could never really
be proved wrong until now a new and
improved bail test
closes both loopholes using both
electrons and photons the scientists
started off with two unentangled and
isolated electrons over a kilometer
apart both existing in two states at
once each of these was entangled with a
photon then they made the photons
interact with each other so that they
also became entangled so now the first
electron is entangled with a photon
that's entangled with another photon
that's entangled with the second
electron you've now got two entangled
electrons over a kilometer apart and
using this new method the scientists
found that when you measure the state of
one electron it does indeed
instantaneously determine the state of
the other Einstein was wrong quantum
physics really is
you